in six hours you your government and 124
million other people across 14 states
will be tested by the greatest disaster
to ever hit the US East Coast a great
wave 1000 meters tall moving towards you
at 1000 km/h and that's only the
beginning Boston New York Philly DC
Miami all underwater and you this is
what if and here's what would happen if
a megatsunami hit the US East Coast
unlike most tsunamis that are triggered
by tectonic activity megatsunamis are
caused by sudden impact a huge chunk of
debris possibly a meteor smashes the
water creating a huge wave which might
reach thousands of meters high the
initial super wave would set off a chain
reaction of smaller waves in all
directions but by smaller we really mean
they'd be about 100 meters high instead
of 1,000 depending on the size and
location of the impact and the speed of
the waves racing towards you you may get
a few hours of warning but will that be
enough time welcome to la palma one of
the seven main Canary Islands home to 81
thousand people and a giant scary
volcano suppose it erupts and the
eruption is big enough that it triggers
a massive landslide massive enough to
send a billion tons of rock sliding into
the ocean causing a megatsunami the
initial wave is 914 meters high it
surges upwards and outwards setting off
a chain reaction of deadly waves in all
directions in six hours a series of 30
meter waves will batter the American
East Coast ramming speed
speed
900 km/h one of the seven deep ocean
assessment and reporting boys floating
along the Atlantic coast will
undoubtedly register this mega
displacement of lauder giving the u.s.
tsunami warning center time to alert
anyone who might be in danger the only
problem is that's 38% of the American
population the entire US East Coast
would be affected
putting 14 States and 124 million people
including key members of the government
at risk if you can't make it out in time
then climb in major cities the newest
and tallest skyscrapers would be the
safest places to go and your own safety
would be entirely your responsibility
since emergency services wouldn't really
be able to take action until the
onslaught was over in the best case
scenario you've managed to evade the
disaster completely your family is safe
but your home not so much worse you're
on the roof of a skyscraper safe with a
group of survivors waiting for a
helicopter to come pick you up which
might take a very long time but in the
worst-case scenario the death toll would
be staggering
the economic impact easily costing
billions if not trillions of dollars it
will take decades to rebuild and yet is
it wrong to suggest that we might have
gotten off easy how much worse would it
have been without the six hours of
advance notice that's right you owe a
big THANK YOU to these super smart boys
monitoring the coast keeping you safe
and dry so that you can rest easy and
keep watching what if